on va passer une petite interview il va
n'a très sympathique c'est un petit jeu
un espace sans importance
ça s'appelle l'interview alerte rouge
[Musique]
bien calé ivana trump votre première
pensée quand vous vous trouvez en face
d'un homme séduisant les ragas bas
quasiment nul et on a envie de le tenir
dans ses bras
et puis le troisième chose je vais pas
mentir il est avec l'audace et on a
envie de tenir dans ses bras beaucoup ça
vous donne une idée
ce rêve mais je me dis pas la troisième
y aller quel est pour vous le quel est
pour vous il va notre frein la fille du
designer italien passé c'est plutôt
l'absence est mal placée elle a dit que
jésus n'dam attention je vais pas dire
moi aussi qu'elle est calé pour vous il
va naître un peu le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte sans la plage on a collé au
chai et on sait jamais ce qui va se
passer après la la la
et moi
c'est et essayiste booking mais c'est
toi et regarde et c'est toi qui à la
barre surtout avec les italiens la
madone attention à la consultation
c est ce que vous préférez draguer ou
vous faire draguer bon c'est toujours
l'homme qui donne droit qui s'est bien
vengé ce que je fais tout ça bon c'est
alors de venir à moi c'est ça qui c'est
ça qui leur plaît aux hommes les jo il
aime travailler pour venir vous chercher
est ce que vous préférez largué vous
faire larguer
non non c'est moi qui l'équipe ah c'est
vous que j'ai dit et ça il faut vous
draguer mais après c'est vous quitter
mais s'il est passé mais c'est pas
gentil mais je dis attention
est ce qu ont préféré embrasser ou qu on
vous embrasse
j'aime bien les embrasser les hommes on
sent que j'aime pas ça c'est eux qui
m'embrasse mais j'aime bien passé j'ai
chaud j'ai chaud j'ai changé chat
l'aspect très blonde cheveux blonds l'a
bien alors des problèmes
est-ce que je vais avoir des ennuis dès
ce que no problemo ivana trump est ce
que vous conservez un fantasmes
inavouables of crowds bien sûr et je ne
vais pas l'admettre mais pas me
confesser est ce que vous croyez que et
ses fantasmes
eh bien il reste nécessaire de vous
souvent on essaie de lévis vous essayez
pas de vivre tous vos fantasmes quand
vous vous trouvez ça plus sexy de les
garder en vous plutôt que de les vivre
je sais les deux j'ai trié les deux
dernières questions il va naître un pack
war connaissez-vous la passion qui s'est
a soumissionné
d'abord ça dépend de la personne si on
parle d'une véritable relation bien sûr
que ce sont des signes mais peut-être un
peu moins de faire l'amour au lieu de le
faire tous les jours on le fait tous les
deux jours vient entre moyens éléments à
tout d'un coup vous voyez votre homme
qui se teint les cheveux qui se fait
couper les cheveux qui fait des choses
différentes de ce qui fait d'habitude et
il ya des signes qui font qu'on sait
qu'un homme à une liaison par exemple
par exemple il rentre tard à la maison
bon c'est pas ce qui m'est arrivé un
moral vous êtes de bons conseils merci
merci la preuve en est
pendant le dîner
[Musique]
goss et pas bougé bernard debré quelle
est votre première pensée quand vous
rencontrez une fille très très très très
joli je te laisse la place j'en ai
rencontré une je regrette simplement qui
est quelqu'un trois mois on arrive à
météo c'est que je pense qu'on va garder
ces salles alerte
ces alertes aux roses maintenant je vous
posais une question que j'ai vu posé
dernièrement sur tf1 par un dénommé
benjamin castaldi qui avait demandé de
baisser la lumière d'ailleurs je
félicite le nourrir de cette émission
bravo et récréatifs et pourtant aussi
une question de très banal au fond quel
est pour vous bernard debré le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte la voiture ah
bon non non pas du tout non non
saturation
j'y vais tous les ans ici sinon il faut
choquer allongez vous mademoiselle alors
j'ai bien lu tout dans quel benjamin
castaldi tu notes les questions non
parce que le mec qui fait la même chose
sur tf1
où êtes-vous incapable de faire l'amour
au bloc opératoire aussi un bon d'accord
on ne fait pas des rats cendre on a le
droit d'être humble mais une fois que
l'opération ait commencé c'est qu'on
s'est compliqué à faire mais ça baise à
l'hosto n'en as a doit baisser alors
cessons c'est là où j'ai rencontré ma
femme
tiens justement on y arrive a réfléchi
concentrez vous est ce que vous préférez
une femme qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle ou une femme qui baissent bien
mais qu'un fidèle à moi je préfère une
femme qui baisent bien et qui soit
fidèle au même temps sera instable chez
la mienne est d'accord bien que vous
préférez draguer ou faire draguer à vous
faire draguer sur le têt merveilleux
vous faire draguer non il est plus sympa
que son frère président la vérité est ce
que vous préférez embrassez vous faire
embrasser à ça je vois pas la différence
car ici nous apprécier est ce que vous
préférez qu'a réussi à vous faire
caresser alternativement préféré larguer
ou faire larguer ont largué pour ce
qu'une chose servir de bray très
important benjamin tu notes
est-ce que vous conservez un fantasme
non réalisés ah oui
paquin vous en occupez vous cherchez à
l'assuré oui quand vous pensez que le
jour où vous allez mourir vous aurez
réaliser tous vos fantasmes
à ce moment là je réaliserai pas tous
mes fantasmes pour ne pas mesurer
réaliser ben non parce que si je me dis
une fois que j'ai tout réaliser je vais
mourir ben je réaliserai patins
[Musique]
oui qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce qui va se
passer d'eux muriel ne t'en fais pas ta
c
muriel prendre mûrir calme-toi to value
de traduire la chanson céline renaud qui
chante son déclin incroyable c'est une
chanson lino bien alors ça s'appelle
l'interview d'arthrose
scheer est ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou es ce que
vous avez besoin de faire l'amour pour
aimer le premier vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour et les femmes
les hommes et je croyais que je
changerais les hommes ils ont besoin de
faire l'amour pour aimer scheer on se
concentre adultère
friedrich vous trompe imaginons vous
préférez ne pas savoir où vous êtes
partisan de tout vous dire disent rien
mais que j'ai bien sûr le droit de le
tuer oh la la la la
est ce que vous préférez un mec qui
baissent très bien mais qui est infidèle
ou un mec qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle
j'ai déjà pris des rides y est allé de
deux châssis la première fois qu'on
aurait pensé un peu plus rien c'est
vraiment fait pour une femme pour s
amuser à la can am de toute façon donc
bien sûr si c'est pour s'amuser autant à
voir l'homme qui n'est pas fidèle dans
ce cas là je n'aurai pas besoin d'être
fidèle moi même quel est pour vous le
lieu idéal pour une étreinte le lieu
idéal pour le sexe dans une voiture non
pourquoi
c'était dans la préfecture et des levées
dans l'amérique profonde chez elle faute
à monseigneur dans le carrosse
j'ai essayé mais est-ce que vous avez
scheer ait un fantasme que vous n'avez
pas encore réalisé 10 et à voir je crois
que je vous ai toujours inutiles comme
tout le monde mais encore un truc j'ai
pas osé faire quoi oui tout à fait et
vous cadrez mais les fantasmes ça va ça
vient ça change tout
il faut vite les réaliser sinon après ça
change de forme donc on est d'accord
alors maintenant cette question m'a été
envoyé par georges avec un j est ce que
vous préférez
l'amour cinq fois par jour toute votre
vie et que le même homme ou une fois par
mois toute votre vie est quand même
différent je crois que cinq fois par
jour bien alors un autre email une
question email d'arnaud si friedrich
rate un rendez vous important
l'après midi et qui vient faire l'amour
avec vous vous lui dit tu es fou où tu
me rend folle
eh bien je dirais oui non ou bien tu me
rend folle vous le dirai pas tu es fou
ouais yes ouïe ouïe
qu'est ce que richard ardoise et vince
valeur d'oise sortie schirrhein the
thing
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non c'est il est lent mais tu n'y a plus
non plus à rallonge et bien alors ça
s'appelle l'interview alerte aux roses
c'est tombé sur vos aïeux quelle est
votre première pensée jeunes moreau
lorsque vous trouvez quand même et
séduisant salut jamais ça va doit
langage vous engager est ce que vous
préférez draguer ou vous faire draguer
les gays les embrasser vous faire
embrasser en ligue 1
les trains en même temps caressé ou vous
faire caresser pareil de larguer ou
faire larguer garnier la galerie
boulakia quel est pour vous le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte l'été à l'ombre
l'hiver au chaud
quel est le lieu où vous seriez
incapable de faire l'amour le space
mountain près d'une poubelle a prévu une
poubelle
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour de faire l'amour pour
aimer ça dépend des relations
des fois ça commence ça peut commencer
par le sexe et venir de l'amour oui
d'accord
est ce que vous préférez attention c'est
très grave ça mais un mec qui bosse bien
mais qu'un infidèle ou un mec lieberman
mais qui fit d'elle ni l'un ni l'autre
ah bon je recherche un troisième oui ses
fidèles
m
[Applaudissements]
alors au sujet si j'ai de l'adultère est
ce que vous préférez pas savoir où tout
ce n'est la pas d'adultère savons que
c'est un mot à la fin du 19e siècle
avant ça existe plus d'une liaison
préféré le mot liaison non ça va ça
vient tout ça abonde actuellement oui tu
te soumets donc voilà donc on n'en parle
même pas mais on en parle
ces faits n'existent pas maniant la
sculpteure c'est un tel cliché ya des
gens qui foutent leur relation a l'air
pour ça ça vaut pas la peine d'inventer
un nouveau mot pour ça je sais pas on
n'en parle pas c'est tout allons donc
papa de ma réponse est ce que vous
conservez dernière question à fantasmes
non réalisés mais d'état ah oui vous
pensez les réaliser non justement ça
martin oui vous pensez que les pompes à
penser que c'est plus excitant de se
parer la saris vibrer céline atteignable
une fois que c'est fait c'est fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien vous n'êtes pas bougé audrey
des gens formidables
vous êtes des leurs mais sympa quand
même les prélats l'autre le ben fist
attiches ressemble mois castaldi et il
semble qu'on ait fait ça non
balle au centre moi la différence c'est
que je te met pas la main sur la jambe
pour pas que tu parles était l'ami
ailleurs fait bien attention audrey
marnay on se concentre
[Musique]
vous êtes bouddhistes en plus qu'en
penser ah j'ai beaucoup de mannequins
sont bouddhistes
oui ça cause de quoi non pour moi c'est
plutôt une façon de penser de rapprocher
deux niveaux de séverine ferrer vous
savez que séverine ferrer élévation de
la pensée avec séverine faire rencontrer
le dalaï lama
elle est venue nous le raconter ici mais
le bel ami le dalaï lama est déjà venu à
chartres aussi un bon bien sûr quand vos
parents
quand mes parents il est venu à la
maison a laissé sa i vé ça passe bien
moi je pense qu'ils sont plusieurs en
fait alors est ce que vous préférez
draguer ou vous faire draguer ben c'est
intéressant parce quand je me fais
draguer je suis un mur est d'accord un
possible mandat c'est bon à savoir est
ce que vous préférez largué ou vous
faire larguer largué j'ai toujours
quitter mais mes conquêtes d'enfance on
va dire puisque j'ai que 20 ans attend
puis alexandre fait un moment maintenant
et donc et je me suis jamais fait
larguer comme on dit
donc je pense toujours larguée vous
préférez caresser ou vous faire caresser
ça dépend des jours aujourd'hui par
exemple
maintenant c'est sûr j'aurais été sur la
voyait arriver c'est parti
les gentils je travaille pour toi alors
[Rires]
bien ça dépend des jours donc
aujourd'hui c'est un jour avec
puisque mon âme est à new york donc
aujourd'hui peut-être et sous-préfets
vous faire embrasser ou embrasser
j'aime bien quand ça vient des deux
septennats simultanément il ya un désir
simultanées vous croyez au désir
simultanées est-ce qu'on prête à l'amour
fusionnel
ou est ce que vous croyez qu'il faut pas
trop se marcher sur les pieds de materna
salle de bains faut pas trop ce marché
saint-pierre matin mais on peut
fusionner bien est-ce que vous avez
besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de
faire l'amour pour aimer pour faire des
mets pour faire l'amour et vous tombez
armées noël vous était pas sur l'image
du code interbancaire rodelin symbole
les deux réalisatrices uniquement pour
marquer je ne joue pas je vous laisse
seul avec vanessa chacun sa merde
oui
on se concentre aurait marne et si votre
vrai nom marne et oui c'est en plus de
vingt noms qu'ils allaient tout de suite
bien quoi parce que ça fait un peu
pseudo audrey marnay c'est un peu comme
axelle red
si bien que c'est ça le souriceau obama
redira un pseudo tellement c'est beau
non ils étaient plus longs au moyen âge
c'était quoi marnette vernon au en plus
elle a une particule mais sa lettre elle
a été vendue il ya il en vend du quel
est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte à
part le podium j'irai la plage à la
plage on jeu le jour la nuit le jour le
jour et le lieu où étaient incapables de
faire la mer qui va être content si nous
regarde
bonjour maman mais vous avez vingt ans
maintenant vous êtes si malin maxime
fait ce que vous faites sous couvert d
chardy sont à partir de 20 ans ils
peuvent venir
je serais incapable de faire l'amour
backstage sonner chez huawei alors qu'un
pas qu'ils font oui vous préférez alors
l'attention c'est compliqué un mec qui
bosse bien mais qui est infidèle ou un
mec est fidèle béquille beige mâle qui
baisent malin fidèles moi je suis très
pour la fidélité
ah oui vous prêtez même si beaucoup
non mais ça peut s'apprendre à il va
prendre à new york en pensez quoi
est ce que je pourrais vous poser la
question la mi temps oui moi je réponds
comme jeanne moreau gens cherchent
chercher une 3e d'accord voilà une qui
est fidèle et qui bossent bien voilà
mais audrey alors c'est marrant si vous
êtes la première à me répondre ça sert
vous vous en foutez qui baisent mal vous
vous dites je vais lui apprendre
non mais c'est bien qu'elle réponde ça
parce que c'est pas la mode justement 6
et participons 10 de ses convictions
c'est bien là la ses convictions c'est
une douleur d'une famille bien
imaginons parlons d'adultère c'est un
jeu de l'esprit bien entendu le jeu vous
voyez bien un mariage je vous demande de
quitter le professeur et des visions
deux minutes si madame marc n'est pas
allé chercher une bière dans le frigo
est ce que vous préférez pas savoir par
exemple ce qui fait en ce moment il
préfère pas le savoir où vous dites tous
ces couples on se raconte tout si on du
tout jeunesse de partir nous regarde
alexandre du buzz moi j'ai pas voulu
dire ça non c'est pas ça
ce qu'elle la méthylation d'accord
comment elle lui avait appris aux quais
est est-ce que vous avez des fantasmes
encore non réalisés oui pas mal
ah bon et vous comptez moment j'ai le
temps oui il a 20 ans bien sûr j'en ai
un tous les jours donc un fantasme tous
les jours on pas gâcher tout ça
il a de la chance alexandre et c'est
pour ça qu'ils se barrent merci andré
vous n'êtes pas parler de choses moins
sérieuses pourquoi pas cette embauche
favori jingle on ne bouge pas pendant
les guerres
[Musique]
c'est un gage série s'est engagé à pas
bougé pendant le jingle pendant toute la
soirée à condition que je fasse le gage
qu'il a marqué sur ce papier et chaque
fois qu il le montre à quelqu'un tout le
monde est mort de rire que montrent les
agents une bonne façon de faire de la
politique en tous les cas je vous trouve
qu'ils me disent rien cacher aux
français je joue j'ai appliqué tout de
suite la théorie monsieur le ministre
quel est votre première pensée lorsque
vous trouvez une femme séduisante et
j'admire c'est tout c'est la première
qu'elle est qu'elle est le lieu idéal
pour une étreinte un lit ah ouais vous
n'êtes pas bon je dois la chaîne m'a
attrapé dans la safrane avec les motards
à la question la question le lieu idéal
à mon avis la safrane ce n'est pas idéal
mais non quel est le lieu justement vous
seriez incapable c'est un jeu de
l'esprit bientôt de vous seriez
incapable de faire l'amour à sa femme
l'aca est ce que vous avez besoin de
faire l'amour pour aimer ou des mets
pour faire l'amour de faire l'amour pour
aimer mais à vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pourrait même oui alors
s'attache à 128,6 dépression à temps
c'est des questions compliquées
gouvernement ils n'ont pas des questions
de ce moment là tous les jours un cd
mini c'est un truc qu'on n'aborde pas ça
ne pas beaucoup aussi parce que vous
faites des déjeuners avec une banda
comme ils s'appellent votre club là
démarre en outaouais c'est vous dire
qu'il a cédé ma club
ils ont un qi c'est vrai oui
5 la craie donc il devient club ché ché
l'oiseau la dernière fois sur le nez
rouge non il ya martine aubry dans le
club sans déconner sérieux ça doit être
top
est ce que vous préférez gens de
l'ennemi une femme qui baisent bien avec
un fidèle ou une femme qui baissent mal
mais qui est fidèle
julien julien il était tranquille 10
gbit s est génial je crois que je vais
dire qui mais ce bien qui est un fidèle
avez vous préféré parce qu'il ya des
gens qui demandent qu'à faire ouais
oui autant prendre du plaisir ouais si
elle a qui disent bon celle qui baisent
mal etc et fidèle au moins je vais lui
apprendre à bien baisés donc il ya des
mecs qui se croient pygmalion hell's ass
et vaniteux l'arrogance française tous
d'accord je prends d'autres d'une part
sam sorte de joker d'autre part je
donnerai mon fils comme s'arrête à la
veille de noël il se pique les cadeaux
regardez le regard de la poupée si on
dirait peter falk réaliser des igloos et
les meilleurs volants l est vers on
regarde on arrête
sin jetables c'est pas bien alors est ce
que vous préférez dans un couple tout
vous dire où rien savoir s'il réalise
que je suis
[Musique]
bon je passais une question abandonne
alors ça c'est une question qui m'a été
enlevée par un téléspectateur laquelle à
vous allez voir croyez vous écoutez bien
julien ça peut vous tomber dessus vous
n'êtes pas à l'abri
voyez vous que les femmes épris préfère
pensez vous que les femmes préfèrent
être prise sans qu'on les comprenne
plutôt que comprises sans qu'on les
prennent il s'appelle john barch bravo
[Applaudissements]
croyez vous que les femmes préférées
depuis cinq ans et qu'on dirait plutôt
bien compris ainsi finalement être
comprise bon sens qu'on les prennent
notamment attention on va passer à
l'interview alerte aux roses est prête
en accouchant
mapping bouge pas pendant le temps de
bush on est mort
bush par le bouge pas pendant le génial
bien interview alerte aux roses
quand vous trouvez un homme séduisant
quelle est votre première pensée bas
maintenant c'est plus pareil
oui annoncé que je me serais bien ouais
et maintenant maintenant si je veux même
pas à vous voyez
non non j'en par une copine ah oui
d'accord à fougerolles quel est le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte pour vous bon
avis ou peut-être en apesanteur
ça doit durer super longtemps tous
attrapé tout le lieu où vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour dans la neige
préférez draguer vous faire draguer mais
je connais pas draguer mais j'ai
toujours draguer ouais ouais
oui vous l'avez de règlement préféré
embrasser vous faire embrasser me faire
masser caresser vous faire caresser sert
les deux à la fois largués ou faire
larguer narguer alors maintenant
question très importante
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer ça a changé pareil ouais ouais
ouais une époque c'était plutôt faire
l'amour pour m et puis maintenant on on
s'est aimés pour faire l'amour avec lui
on vous ans et connu trop tard
finalement est ce que vous préférez un
mec qui bosse bien mecha fidèles ou un
mec qui baisent malbec et fidèle bas
généralement comme si moi qui drague
c'est moi qui choisis
ouais donc tant qu'à faire je vais
prendre équipe est bien et puis même
s'il a un peu un fidèle non mais je
m'arrangerais sympa voilà c'est ce
qu'elles disent tout et oui c'est ça
justement alors dans un coup pensé qu'il
faut tous dire pour rien se dire rien se
dire rien non pas rien et pas tout ouais
un peu mais par exemple si vous aviez
une aventure vous lui diriez votre jeu
ça peut arriver vous êtes marrants ben
oui safari mais je m'arrêter un an j'ai
pas vous dire impôts après l'émission
donc vous dites un peu sans produire
tout en disant quoi ça dépend si c'est
un peu comme ça non à un coup comme ça
ah oui en 83e mais c'est important ça si
c'est un accident si c'est ça c'est
intéressant un accident vous j'ai désole
la glycine après je m'excuse abat donc
voilà vous êtes comme en voit ce niveau
là vous êtes partisan de tout se dire ou
du questionnaire je sais quand on alors
cantona est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut
attention et elle est dure celle là est
ce que vous pensez
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimait répéter
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour si vous ne pouvez faire
l'amour ou jallet ou alors ou alors au
contraire vous faites l'amour finit
séparés mais non j'ai besoin d'aidé mais
par amour
bon alors est ce que vous préférez que
ce soit allumé ou éteint dernière
question aux ennemis allumé à la la quel
dommage
bon allez ciao vous savez quand on ne
bouge pas pendant le djing à la respecte
c'est le concept de l'émission je le
fond c'est bien on avoue je pars pendant
le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah quel bonheur des qui a pu baffie non
mais tu es censé c'est vraiment il
revient alors patrick est ce que vous
avez besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
ou de faire l'amour pourrait mais j'ai
besoin d'aidé mais pour faire l'amour ah
ouais la majorette
mais la majorette des petits blancs ça
va mais tout était très petit ah oui
vous avez besoin d'aimer pour ça oui
évidemment suivi un geste est
accompagnée et est accompagnée d'un
sentiment je veux dire d'un truc
oui oui alors vous préférez une femme
qui baisent bien c'est bien entendu mais
qui est infidèle ou une femme qui
baisent mal mais qui est fidèle mais moi
je veux bien l'initié si si elles
baisent mal
peut-être qu'elle sera moins fidèles
ouais bah oui d'accord oui vous avez lu
à prendre après les renvois l'intérieur
c'est que ces kiss & kill
malheureusement il ya des lacunes et
mais je veux bien réparer le oui les
blessures vous êtes sympa quand même
bah on est là pour ça et me dire les
pieds en même temps tu peux y apprend
des nouveaux trucs tout ça alors dans le
couple est ce que vous êtes partisan de
de rien savoir ou de tout se dire
je pense que de tout se dire c'est bien
parce que ça fait tomber les tabous et
et c'est bien tout se dire si j'étais
tromper way ou jetés ou patati et patata
a fait mieux patati patata
après ça dépend avec qui je peux pas
trouver ces c'est plus simple quoi ça
permet de mieux communiquer je crois que
ce oui c'est plutôt tout se dire tout se
dire même si ça doit amener la rupture
et ben oui parce que de toute façon même
si on vous dit rien la rupture qu'elles
ont les connaissances mais n'aurait
imaginé que ce soit pour un soir vous
sortez dans une boîte une aventure avec
une fille faisait cannes le raconter
avec votre fiancée habituel mais oui
parce que toute façon mais je crois que
elle le sera quoiqu'il arrive parce que
tout se sait un jour ou l'autre donc ça
sert à rien de mentir des menteurs qui
ont aussi regardé les mensonges du début
de leur vie jusqu'à la fin de leur vie
je ne connais pas beaucoup mais moi je
tente ma femme elle le sait pas mais
c'est justement je suis également
inquiet évidemment j'aurais du mal à pas
lui dire ça n'est pas ça voilà les
missions économiques à la beauté tromper
sa part déposé pour vous être contre les
pauvres jusqu'à on va faire ça se
discute alors ma voix et stylos oui
alors vous c'est vachement bien
je le ferai bon je suis enrhumé aulas
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
à l'arrière d'une voiture mardi d'accord
et avec des gens autour d'un parking et
regarde ça existe ça c'est la porte
ça c'est la courageuse c'est la plante
deux films ça beau fils jean 3 l'endroit
où vous ne pourriez pas faire l'amour
patrick sur eux
dans des toilettes à bord vous ça vous
plaît pas ça c'est pas possible
il dit que les toilettes il n'arrive pas
à faire la demande dans les toiles non
mais j'essaierai même pas d'abord sur un
ipad dans la pièce non mais dans les
toilettes parce que sur un terrain près
mais quitte à laisser la bombe
d'hiroshima
c'est le way bien alors sérieusement je
peux faire et draguer ou faire draguer
me faire draguer elle sous pression' est
largué vous faire larguer elle argué
largué moi j'ai ce qui s'est passé on a
dit qu'on en parle et plus on en
attendait non arrêté ne répondait pas
dans la jal et déjà les jokers non non
non ne répondait pas demain on a dit
qu'on n'en parlait plus on a parlé voilà
vous préféré embrasser ou faire au mas
et là me faire embrasser oui on va te
faire manger la boue je crois qu'une
graine comme ça comme ça ouais ouais
vous préférez caresser ou faire caresser
faut vraiment c'est vraiment un jour ou
l'autre je caressais je crois que vous
aimez donner du plaisir votre partenaire
plein trip absolument pas ce que ça veut
dire à ce sport qui va être poursuivie
ne majorait courte tournée vous mettez
déjà vous aurez du mal à sortir du
placard s'annonce certes à vire alors
fiori
[Rires]
alors est-ce que vous avez infante alors
que vous n'avez pas encore réaliser un
fantasme que je n'ai pas encore réalisé
on reste toujours d'un sujet sexuelle ou
a tellement d'autres en même temps
je fasse il ya monseigneur di falco
après on parlera de relations
compliquées puisque franck anne a
beaucoup avant on faisait encore plein
de fantasmes c'est par elle il y en a
énormément et on est tous pareils faut
pas se leurrer dès qu'on a passé end
on va connaître un autre ça laisse
rêveur tout ça
c'est tout
son corps
c
on ne bouge pas de signal
[Applaudissements]
bien c'est quoi qui a bougé serge elle a
bougé pendant le jingle hume jing
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
à ali avait tout simplement vous
préférez draguer ou faire draguer me
faire draguer ah bon on peut être chaîne
de garder mes stars préférées largué ou
faire larguer me faire larguer ça m'est
jamais arrivé et largué je peux pas le
faire c'est la vie qui s'en charge mais
c'est ce que je sais pas faire moi vous
préféré embrasser ou faire embrasser
embrassez vous préférez caresser vous
faire caresser vais faire caresser
là on a tout le mode d'emploi du lieu où
vous seriez incapable de faire l'amour
la fourrière
vous avez besoin d'aimer pour faire
l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour aimer
de faire l'amour pour aimer oui peut pas
baiser comme ça vraiment pas si je peux
mais je tombe amoureuse après d'accord
enfin si ça peut très bien fait comme il
faut est ce que vous préférez un mec qui
bosse bien mais qu'un infidèle ou un mec
qui baisent mal mais qui est fidèle qui
pèse bien qu'un fidèle
ouais parce qu'on peut toujours corriger
le tir pour certaines choses et pas pour
d'autres
pas de podium est pour toi dans le
complet ce que vous être partisane en
dit partisan artisanale partisane
quelque chose de grave mais est-ce que
vous êtes partisan de rien savoir où
tout se dire
c'est la question la plus importante
cela la seule question qui intéresse des
millions de gens qu'est ce que je vais
dire on t'a rien savoir
et puis jolie excuse et des fantasmes
non encore réalisé ouais ce qui vous
attend maintenant vous savez qu'on ne
bouge pas dans le jingle jean marc barr
savez ça on bouge pas vraiment génial on
bouge pas fameuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien alors interview alerte aux roses
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
voilà c'est la plage la plage voilà le
lieu vous êtes incapable de faire
l'amour un bus vous préférez draguer
vous faire draguer j'aime mieux c'est
draguer moi même me vous aimez préféré
larguer ou vous faire larguer pas
souvent c'est moi qui me fait larguer
donc en savoure encore plus séduisant me
dire ça vous fait larguer vous oui mais
c'est comme c'est comme ça je ne crois
pas quand je vous vois là c'est à dire
que je suis sensible préféré embrasser
ou vous faire embrasser
j'aime bien le partager donc j'espère
que la personne que j'embrasse membres
associe pareil pour lui caresse
exactement est-ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de faire
l'amour pour aimer attrait fille de se
fixer à l'amour et le sexe sont pas liés
ouais vous préférez une fille qui
baisent bien un mec est infidèle ou une
fille qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle
le premier la mifi qui baissent bien
mais qu'un fidèle et vous anthony ou
aussi pouvoir vous pensez vous la rendre
et fidèle qua non parce que c'est plus
agréable
je veux le président bourges bonsoir
président bien alors dans le couple vous
pensez qu'il faut pas savoir où tout se
dire tiens ça c'est des questions mais
sincèrement je pense qu'il vaut mieux
pas savoir et rien lire voilà il faut
pas il faut rien dire rien dire vous
êtes en prison ne rien dire on dit le
contraire mais pour moi ça a toujours
été le cas
quand vous êtes un petit peu ouverts à
une compagne à chaque fois au bout d'un
moment j'ai pas le courage d'être net
sur des choses qui sont un petit peu
contradictoire j'essaie mois de mai
tendance c'est une bonne réponse mais
pas le courage d'être honnête sur des
choses qui sont contradictoires et vous
joker à ses subordonnés
en même temps c'est pas votre interview
anthony joker et une bière vous pensez
qu'il faut pas savoir où tout se dire
pas ça dépend il y en a qui veulent dire
jamais je pose une question
ça dépend vous êtes bretonne êtes pas
normande
non mais moi moi je dit pareil je sais
rien mais si on me demande des bains je
dirai où la vérité ou pas ça dépendra
vous a plutôt tendance à dire la vérité
ça dépend
7 ne bronche pas dinner le bush me
couche pas voir le bush par le single
j'admire même ouais
on essaie de courir derrière bord m'a
dit désolé dans la vie il n'ya pas que
ça qu'être avec ok voilà pourquoi il a
laissé partir aux etats-unis quelle est
votre première pensée
judith godrèche lorsque vous rencontrez
un homme séduisant
où vais-je ouais vous préférez draguer
ou faire draguer la cassette par les
routes de noix comme ça il ce concours
draguer préféré embrasser ou vous faire
embrasser me faire embrasser roxas fait
de way attendre à quelqu'un en
l'occurence il est content que tu peux
te jeter sur lui j'avais une chance de
survie siaka des gambas et sa cave et
pour vous j'ai dit brèche le lieu idéal
pour une étreinte attend que je
réfléchisse
ben oui quoi ouais vous auriez d'une
plage ça l'aurait tué d'être le lieu où
vous êtes incapable de faire l'amour ben
les toilettes
ah bon mais c'est vachement sympa bah
ouais pour sa rentrée sur moi je vais
déjà fait
elle se prête avec caresser ou vous
faire caresser ou ça
mais les indiens
et maintenant seigneur sith nous
entraîne vers mes péchés la baisse alors
ça c'est très important
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer des mets pour faire l'amour ah bon
on peut pas faire l'amour sans aimer si
je peux mais c'est pas forcément une
réussite
alors voilà une question aussi très
intéressante pour nos amis américains
est ce que vous préférez un mec qui
bosse bien mais qui est infidèle ou un
mec qui baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
du blé mais qui qui vont très vite et
tout est lié au bout de deux minutes
voilà j'ai connu ça vous avez connu ça
deux accusateurs précoce ouais ça doit
être terrible on sait mais c'est
terrible mais quand on est une fille ont
toujours trouve toujours des excuses à
tous ouais ça mais mme ducharme en fait
ouais non c'est vrai puis moi je peux en
forme hier donc dès qu un mec a plein de
problèmes à la limite c'est donc vous
préférez un mec qui bosse bien aimé
qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui bosse mâles
des quais fidèle infidèle dans un
couvent ou penser qu'il vaut mieux tout
se dire ou rien savoir
tout se dire ah bon mais je pense que
l'infidélité c'est un langage c'est un
mode de langage c'est pour dire à
l'autre tu assures plus ça va parfois le
problème ça c'est très fort en même
temps très fort et je t'es trompé en
arriver là c'est vraiment ce que je
couche avec lui ça va pas entre nous
moi je pense qu'une fois qu'on a trompé
quelqu'un c'est fini tu crois ouais
c'est très difficile mais une fois que
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un et après c'était
fini quoi il n'y a pas moyen de mesurer
les morceaux ce que tu dis est ce à la
personne est suspicieuse à tout moment
je vous l'aviez dit vous bien il l'a
découvert mais moi je faisais tout pour
que cela se sache vous êtes une fille
très spécial oui tu me la corne est ce
que vous pensez qu'on peut tout faire
quand on aime
ouais tout tout tout tout ouais là rien
de sale en amour non saison du polémique
est-ce que vous avez un fantasme non
encore assouvi vraiment avec des pommes
de terre
[Rires]
non non mais j'ai pas tellement de
fantasmes
ah bon ou alors vous avez tout à sauver
ils sont peut-être à inhiber théâtre
j'ai pas tellement de fantasmes
y'a pas un truc vous dites ça j'aimerais
bien le faire j'aime bien brasser les
chiens sur la bûche aux gens ne bougent
pas pendant les ting
[Musique]
et si vous préférez draguer vous faire
draguer tu préfères draguer préféré
embrasser vous faire embrasser celle là
j'aurais quand même préféré caresser ou
vous faire caresser
elle est consacrée ce thion je suis
désolé si je faisais pas le dire voilà
la donne va pas sans l'autre
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
n'importe où bonne réponse que sinon
qu'elle est le lieu où vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour en revanche
dans un ascenseur à pourquoi les
immeubles sont passés au en france
je vous ai besoin d'aimer pour faire
l'amour ou de faire l'amour pourrait
mais j'ai besoin des billets souvent les
filles c'est la différence entre les
filles et les garçons
est ce que vous préférez ah oui un mec
qui bosse bien mecha infidèles ou un mec
qui bosse mâles mais qui est fidèle à
faire ne pas à essayer
ouais enfin vérifier si c'est compliqué
comme question oui oui enfin c'est comme
si je peux me permettre
c'est pas la bonne et allez vous marier
vous noterez que remet à 80 dessus bah
oui si l'interview belge ait fait mal on
peut vous le faire
williams r oui c'est le choc ah mais une
fois on peut aussi parler comme ça vous
me disiez mais plutôt de bruxelles ah
oui moi j'adore ah je croyais qu avec
vous je suis ravi ouais ça fait mes
soirées extrême en faut peu finalement
ah oui dans le coup vous vous pensez
qu'il faut pas savoir où tout se dire je
vois qu'il ya des choses qu'il faut se
dire des choses qui ne font pas ça pour
accor est-ce que vous avez des fantasmes
non encore réalisés bien sûr d'abord et
vous
je ne dirai pas lesquels je vous demande
pas avec elle mais maintenant j'essaye
de précéder vous voulez vous voulez
réaliser vous avez dans l'idée de vous
êtes vous acharnez avait réalisé il ya
des idées encore des trucs à faire quoi
c'est adam c'est-à-dire plein cécile
autre âge
la double 10 dinars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une
j'ai bougé d'un petit peu quand même
c'est dur c'est belmondo qui vous a fait
attention il ya lu anaky à la maison etc
montrant attention tu à bouger jean
guéhenno bien alors interview l'arthrose
facile je vous préférez draguer ou faire
draguer me faire draguer mais c'est
souvent le contraire qui se passe
c'est pourquoi personne ne voudrait que
c'est obligé de régler c'est pourquoi
ils ont peur de ce point de vue ils ont
peur d'isabelle alonso
je vous le dis j'en fais partie on est
complexé et c'est vrai parce qu'ils
avaient à m'attendais si vous étiez une
fille qu'elle est jolie c'est un procès
avant noël vous avoue que si elle peut
vous coller un procès non appartient
j'assure les hétéros on est sûr d'avoir
un procès bien elle se préféré larguer
ou faire larguer vous préféré embrasser
ou faire embrasser
adieu les deux
les deux ont préféré caresser vous faire
caresser
ça dépend des moments tout est possible
bah oui alors important est ce que vous
avez besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
ou de faire l'amour pourrait mais j'ai
besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour mais
mais faire l'amour peuvent aider à aimer
un et vous lui enseignez comment passer
commande alors lcd à elle se disait je
suis tranquille toute proposition et on
y va la question vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de faire
l'amour pour aimer un truc de filles en
fait amoureuse pour faire l'amour ça y'a
aucun doute il faudra vraiment je suis
pas sûr
c'est à dire faire l'amour et apprendre
amoureuse non peut être un peu amoureuse
donc même pas oui bah oui d'accord mais
celle inverse de garçons au moins 24
heures dans les garçons le garçon il
faut qu' il faut qu'ils fassent l'amour
pourrait mais euh oui on est très
différent voilà donc il faudra être
pourquoi c'est difficile vient alors le
lieu idéal pour faire l'amour
je ne dirais pas un lieu je dirais
plutôt une ambiance des bougies ah oui
dans les églises
mais un peu un peu sombre mais pas trop
mais oui c'est ça bah justement je vais
vous demander si vous préfériez la
lumière éteinte ou allumer donc des noms
voilà clair obscur et vous en plein des
projecteurs sur scène non je m'offre
avons publié au caire dès l'hymne au
clair de lune très important aussi le
lieu où vous seriez incapable de faire
l'amour sous des néons vice ou des nerfs
c'est vraiment une question d'éclairage
voit à quoi ça tient finalement dingue
vous préférez un mec qui bosse bien mais
qu'un fidèle ou un mec qui baisent mal
mais qui est fidèle
préparez-vous folie ça va tomber sur
vous un garçon qui qui fait bien l'amour
oui parce que sinon ce serait moi qui
serais obligé d'être infidèle à vous non
non non non non qu'ils soient fidèles
tant que 24 heures sur 24
ça me dérange pas parce que je n'aime
pas que ce soit un feeder ah non pas du
tout présentation n'appartient à
personne et personne ne nous appartient
donc c'est clair
[Applaudissements]
on ne peut rien faire contre les envies
et les tentations et quelques quelque
part on a beau faire ce qu'on veut et
comme je ne crois pas du tout un
sentiment qui est très moche qui
s'appelle la jalousie je ne crois pas du
tout un sentiment là donc voilà non je
ne pense pas que paul soit d'accord mais
c'est de l'arnaqué pas d'accord mais il
est très d'accord qu apple
non mais sincèrement je pense qu'il faut
croire la fidélité
et voilà c'est sexy la fidélité bien sûr
à force d'être est quand même femme fait
des trucs insensés il ne faudrait jamais
avec une rencontre d'un soir à savais
pas ça dépend il devrait l'imaginaire de
chacun et non laurent mais dit quelque
chose tu me dire que je suis atterré les
fit mine dégoûtée je draguais jeu base
je suis un fidèle
ce qui n'est pas je fais un résumé de
ses créations c'est que thierry nous a
posé une question tout à fait autres aux
filles qu'il a poussé apple à comment
ils résument à skis voilà donc c'est pas
juste on n'a pas eu la même qu'il ya non
traitée de [ __ ] et retourner bientôt
dans le couple vous pensez qu'il faut
tout savoir ou rien se dire pas tous se
dira pas tout se dire ah oui est-ce que
embrasser s'est trompé je trouve en
trombe plus avec le choeur coeur
quelques sexe ouais m'éclate tête c'est
pas déjà no és que sucer c'est tromper
non mais c'est vrai je demande n'ait pas
joué en tout cas oui un peu quand même
bill clinton disait que non
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
bien est ce que vous préférez draguer ou
faire draguer me faire dérailler
oui largué vous faire larguer largué
bien que
ce soit vraiment très difficile de le
larguer rares peut-être vous faire
embrasser ou faire embrasser embrasser
way caresser vous faire caresser
caresser ouais attention c'est la vie
dure est-ce que vous avez besoin de
faire l'amour pour aimer ou des mets
pour faire l'amour les deux pouvaient
pas faire l'amour si vous aimez pas vous
non en fin de compte moi je peux faire
l'amour mais il faut aimer quoi ouais
c'est ça qu'elle est le lieu idéal pour
faire l'amour pour vous meilleur mois
partout on a envie ouais j'ai aucune
inhibition la mort je sais pas dans les
avions sous une couverture j'ai pas ça
n'a été possible vous aviez manuelle ou
le lieu où il est impossible de faire
l'amour donc si peut-être devant les
autres à vous pourriez pas ça non les
boîtes échangistes pas clients non pas
du tout ouais j'suis pas échangiste du
tout
vous prêtez pas pourquoi est ce vous
préférez une femme qui baisent bien mec
est infidèle ou une femme qui baisent
mal mais qui est fidèle
je crois que je préfère une femme
qui baissent bière et quitta fidèles
ouais vous faites fort de la gare des
fidèles toute façon je pense que si on
bosse bien et la défense c'est vrai vous
préférez une femme qui couche avec un
autre en pensant à vous qui couche avec
vous en pensant à un autre niveau
mais quand même s'il fallait choisir
c'est un jeu de l'esprit richard moi je
pense que je préfère qu'elle coucher
avec moi parce qu'après tout c'est moi
qui couche avec elle même si elle
vous pensez que dans le couple il faut
tout savoir ou rien se dire il ne faut
pas tout savoir
ouais s qu'embrasser s'est trompé non
non on peut embrasser pour moi c'est
notre fils en complet brasse et comment
sur la bouche c'est que la langue
alors bien sûr même avec talent ne s'est
pas trompé par exemple si toute façon
parce que c'est laid ouais c'est vrai si
c'est trop tard c'est dans la tête
marie je l'embrassé s'est trompé bah oui
vous aussi vous dites ça va donc sucer
c'est tromper aussi
[Applaudissements]
bien alors c'est une interview
l'interview alerte aux roses qui
s'enrichit chaque semaine des idées que
m'envoie les téléspectateurs
c'est-à-dire que il m'envoie sans arrêt
des nouvelles questions et donc après da
c'est vous qui les subissent et est-ce
que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour faire
l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour aimer
[Musique]
ça dépend quoi vous n'êtes pas faire
isild le besco non non mais je veux dire
il n'y a pas de règle
mais claude vous avez aimé avant de
faire l'amour vous avez fais l'amour
avant de les méchins l'exemple précis
non je les aimais avant-hier le monde
d'accord et vous avec lelouch
alors moi c'est lui les dessertes dans
une ligue 2 voilà attention là vous
préférez un mec qui bosse bien mais
qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui bosse mâles
mais que les fidèles infidèle et qui
bossent bien ah bon c'est le cas non
j'ai rien de plus drôle nbc
j'aimerais me fait récemment alors est
ce que vous préférez être caressé par
quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu par
quelqu'un qui vous aiment ça c'est des
sujets c'est des sujets du bac c'est
l'exemple même d'une question et autant
de recaler dit que c'était l'exemple
question quels étaient les spectateurs
prédit qu'il a su par quelqu'un qui vous
aime l'autre ni l'un ni l'autre a
préféré qu'il vous quitte pour un homme
ou pour une femme une femme vous
aimeriez pas qui vous quitte mon nom je
comprendrais pas j'aurais l'impression
d'avoir eu affaire à quelqu'un que je
connaissais pas ouais vous préférez qui
couche avec une autre en pensant à vous
qui couche avec vous en pensant à une
autre qui couche avec moi on pense à une
autre ça m'excite rey à tahar gharsa
j'ai dû couper les cheveux pour
contrebalancer fait lui le chemin aux
non mais tu peux pas me demander ça à
chaque émission mais pour elle pas pour
moi mais c'est vieux ça y est on est
dans lé en 2001 tu veux pas faire de
chasse l'année dernière j'allais le
chari
rien
ça toute sa vie on va te demander le
crâneur ya que toi
pas vous enfin l heure dix sont très
bien le seul pour qu'il fait le chat le
lieu idéal pour faire l'amour un
n'importe où chez moi et on est tous
pareil que toi là de ces caisses qui
chante ça
gainsbourg non line renaud elle chante
ça et donne pas en victime
on connaît la question est-ce que
embrasser s'est trompé embrasser s'est
trompé rien non plus sur des matières
non je faisais pas de nom suit avec la
langue et tout ça mais qu'on aimerait
les plus immondes in redmond
je vous en supplie ne changera vous
n'êtes pas là alors alors je disais oui
non mais même sans embrasser je veux
dire ce qui se passe là dedans des fois
c'est 20 fois pire qu'embrasser alors à
bon bah oui donc tu as déjà trompé un
peu dans ta tête
j'ai pas dit ça moi je serais tombé je
serais dégoûté
ah ah le pire est à venir c'est
l'interview à leurs torts aux embauches
pendant 2001 on ne bouge pas pendant le
qinghai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
personne n'a bougé c'est parfait dès
qu'il ya un premier ministre plus
personne bouge j'adore l'interview
l'arthrose comme son nom l'indiqué
michel rocard quel est pour vous le lieu
idéal pour faire l'amour
bompard votre cul marc le lieu où c'est
impossible
le coup c'est impossible je ne sais pas
en tout cas je j'ajouterais volontiers
la couche edimbourg bateau à c'est
agréable dans la couchette dans mon
bateau suprême
ah oui avec le ca verse sa mère fit est
nécessaire il est tout seul avec les
dorades est-ce que vous avez besoin de
faire l'amour pour aimer ou des mets
pour faire l'amour besoin je sais pas
mais ça va pas mal ensemble comme ouais
un peu besoin quand même comme tout le
monde
ouais je pense pas et anormales sur ce
sujet est ce que vous préférez une femme
qui baissent bien un mec est infidèle ou
une femme qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle jamais eu à me poser la question
et vous salam qui bouge bien mais qu'un
infidèle ou une femme qui pèse malbec et
fidèle en fait il n'ya tu préfères vous
allez au bout d'un an ça ça dépend si
c'est pour une nuit même si c'est pour
la vie michel rocard est ce que vous
préférez une femme qui couche avec un
autre en pensant à vous ou une femme qui
couche avec vous en pensant un autre à
vous mettez dans un rivière que j'ai
peur rencontre et ça a dit jean et marie
deux fois mais je crois que
que je suis plutôt fondées espérer
qu'elle pense à moi bien même si elle
couche avec un autre ça vous préférez
alors ça vous amuse mais vous êtes prêts
voilà ça vous amuse toi préféré qu'elle
qu'elle pense à vous dans le couple est
ce que vous pensez qu'il vaut mieux tout
se dire oh rien savoir
c'est le dosage de l'antre 2 qui fait
les bons couples à 1 vous pouvez gérer
tes à cette coupe
bah oui c'est pour ça que j attends je
vous fais cette interruption cette
impression spécialistes est ce que vous
préférez
est ce que préfère être caressé par
quelqu'un qui vous dégoûte ou battu par
quelqu'un qui vous aime a battu par
quelqu'un qui mène à attention vous
seriez un peu non non non on se
renseigne ici vous savez comment c'est
est-ce que vous préféreriez que votre
femme vous quitte pour un homme pour une
autre femme appartenant elle moque
équilibre à l ouest puis devant cra
c'est ça la gauche
peut-être le pacs est ce que embrasser
s'est trompé en on a bon puisque c'est
que cette philosophie que vous
travaillez lhc pagesjaunes membre mâle
juin mais ça dépend du contexte et
j'espère bien que non ouais ouais et
sucer c'est tromper et pardon sucer
c'est tromper non plus non plus
le pire est à venir gérard jugnot
le pire est à venir je vous ai concocté
une petite interview pour vous
spécialement
voici l'interview alerte aux roses
[Musique]
voilà laurent baffie ne bouge plus
parlant le jingle effet très bien comme
ça voilà baffie pas bougé alors allons-y
le lieu idéal pour faire l'amour
michel rocard il répondu tout de suite
non je pense qu'un lycée ce qu'elle
mieux c'est ce qu'il a répondu
quelqu'un dans le public avec thierry
lhermitte une réputation vous maintenant
non non c'est ça de région de guin bien
le lieu pour vous il serait absolument
impossible de faire l'amour
je dirais le seul endroit public ouais
bon temps je t'ai vu une fois tout est
maintenant bien
alors attention là c'est beaucoup plus
complexe est-ce que vous avez besoin de
faire l'amour pour aimer ou des mets
pour faire l'amour des mets pour faire
l'amour ah bon très féminin ouais vous
pouvez pas faire l'amour comme ça sans
aimer sa femme
c'est une explication parce que j'avais
vu choper aussi alors voilà non mais
attendez c'est un jeu de l'esprit ça n'a
rien à voir avec votre pouce de certains
jeux de l'esprit je serai est ce que
vous préférez une femme qui baissent
bien avec un fidèle ou une fan qui
baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
c'est le choix de sophie nord
je préfère une femme fidèle et qui
baisent mal parce qu'on peut toujours
apprendre voilà on peut lui apprendre à
exactement bonne réponse car a répondu
aussi peut-être de ma faute je suis très
ami politique est ce que vous préférez
qu'elle vous quitte pour un homme pour
une femme sans cafés apprend un home
away seriez pas moins jaloux si c'était
une femme non je serai interloquée mais
pourquoi pas dans un couple vous
préférez tout se dire ou rien se dire tu
as droit de faire ça mais non oui cher
c'est tout ça c'est l'empreinte de
moyenne
ah ouais de minutes passées entre les
deux camps tous dirai rien savoir
bah ouais on peut dire certaines choses
pas tous d'accord
la vérité n'est pas toujours bonne année
en même temps il faut se dire sur des
forces essentielles comme tu ès
qu'embrasser s'est trompé ça dépend ce
qui est dans la tronche parce qu'au
cinéma on embrasse d'autres filles oui
mais quand on dit coupe était encore ta
langue dans la bouche
c'est peu ça moi j'ai la chance j'ai peu
de sel comme ça alors embrassé ce
n'était pas trop
bon dernière question est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper il l'a fait aussi
celui-ci ou se faire sucer se faire chez
ces gens là je voulais c'est là bas là
vous êtes entrain sympathisé j'aurais
pas bien est-ce que se faire sucer c'est
tromper clinton lui par exemple il dit
que non salées bompard qui a eu d'accord
gérard jugnot
on va faire une interview à leurs toros
en la mouche mardi
lui
bien permis nous est prête
oui le lieu idéal pour faire l'amour y'a
pas de l'idéal c'est n'importe où
n'importe où ouais n'importe quand ouais
comme des bêtes exagéré non ya pas de
vieux vous avez besoin de faire l'amour
pour aimer ou des mets pour faire
l'amour
un art d'aimer pour faire l'amour même
pas en rêve abonnés mais pour faire la
wii si vous aimez pas en fait pas
l'amour n'a pas même pas en rêve
vous préférez un mec qui bosse bien mais
qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui bosse mâles
mais les fidèles
je déteste la fidélité je hais la
fidélité en bon c'est tout ce que je
déteste le plus au monde pas comme lou
elle où elle annonce que si elle était
amoureuse j'étais une dingue super
jalouse jeu vidéo si vous étiez d'accord
pour vivre circoncis ou non mais ça
c'est différent pas bon quand vous
l'avez quand vous avez l'autre fille
sous les yeux si vous êtes moins jalouse
ou non mais à 3 tu voulais dire quoi
deux filles et un garçon mais ensemble
oui ben oui mais alors peut-être que tu
acceptes quelque chose de différent
s'est pas tu commences avec un mec est
que pour toi et je suis sûr que tu lem
différemment viendront d'un mec que pour
toi mais alors tu feras supporter qui
mais qu'il est même toucher une autre
fille mois pour moi c'est une dure vous
préférez que votre mec vous quitte pour
un homme pour une femme
pourquoi non moi je serais moi je dois
je demander je voudrais pas vous
préférez être caressé par quelqu'un qui
vous répugne ou battu par quelqu'un qui
vous aime
ni l'un ni l'autre ne dit pas mal en est
la nôtre même maintenant non mais là je
peux quand même avoir n'ont ni l'un ni
l'autre mais je comprends les bonnes
soeurs j'ai bien peur qu'à céder
battus doucement alors attention quand
même c'est à nous vous préférez un mec
qui couche avec une autre en pensant à
vous ou un mec qui couche avec vous en
pensant une autre je préfère encore
qu'il est la cruauté penser à quelqu'un
d'autre mais away we like ramos et
celles non
intraitable dans un couvent vous pensez
qu'il faut tous se diront rien savoir
il faut se dire oui jalouse comme vous
battant il est mort là mais qui sait que
si un jour ils vous disent les gt4 dire
non pensée il veut tout jamais car il ya
des mecs bien aussi j'aurai alors est-ce
qu'on brasse s est trompé mais ça dépend
des circonstances
j'ai embrassé vous avouera c'est
quelqu'un ou un bon comme pas pour être
dans l'arizona avec la langue est ou non
non non alors on s'est un peu trompé
quand même comment pensez vous ouais non
j'ai absolument d'accord puis embrassé
sur la bouche avec deux langues s'est
trompé ou pas oui c'est tromper mais
c'est être gentil est pas trompé
beaucoup
[Musique]